and i feel like for me beating off is
more of like marriage
counseling so limit to that point do you
need to
like you your wife is like that's that's
the pace she can maintain and that's
that yes you've got to take care of
yourself
and i'd much instead of like i like to
unload the chamber before i even go on
instagram before i even do anything
because then there's just less of a
chance of me
smart going astray so what what's the
rhythm for the for the katharine family
now
i would say two or three nights a week
okay so it's pretty good rhythm it's a
pretty good rhythm
i'd say
average is one and a half and two to
three you're doing good one two three
nights a week there's the
there's the opportunity where we'll put
our daughter to bed and it's like you
know eight eight thirty but you're tired
and exactly and it's always it's always
a crap shoot where it's like i'll
present the idea to my wife and
and fifty percent of the time she goes
yeah honey let's do
and then another fifty percent of the
time she goes i'm super tired and i get
it i'm always never the other way
where she is or she's yeah sometimes
with me it's the other way no there's
never happened but you you grind harder
than most people and i also
i'm also [ __ ] gross like i mean i
will admit it i
i i'll be i'll hi
i've done this i've beat off in the
bathroom i've done that walked into my
bedroom and my wife's like
can we have sex and i'm like yes we can
oh god bless you
you know you are you're a superhero
because my dick is hurt
it's the only way i can captain america
on a contra team or something
that's the only way i can be somewhat
successful
it's the only way i can be somewhat
successful because i pretty much
ejaculate so much
so i'm lucky my gift is that i can do it
over and over again but i come in like
25 seconds
that's a gift though it's a gift it's a
gift relax
dude and how much is that you guys have
been together a handful
uh we've been married seven years we've
been together probably like a little
under nine and then we have a kid
different animal yeah yeah yeah so you
know i've been through
i've run the cycle right so we're
together since
84 we've got married 91.
we're still three times a week yeah
oh my god you got to get drew's wife on
this show she's the best
three times a week and yeah well that's
after she got the prosthetic limbs
because drew had already [ __ ] smashed
her in half with his
gigantic hebrew hog yeah that's what
gigantic documented
kosher log that he goes in there i've
seen i'll go to visit and or we'll go
out to dinner and
susan just comes in walking like she's
been hoarse sometimes we'll sometimes
pick up beyond that base
it's pretty good that's awesome still is
the butt is the butt open for business
is the butt open for business in the
peninsula oh bro
she was a friend of students you can't
stand it relax i don't know her so
finish this
i think i want too many email changes
i'm not even being gross susan if for a
woman her age is like a ten yeah he's
like honestly very beautiful very that's
that's why i wouldn't expect nothing
less that should be what women aspire to
look like at that age
yeah three times can we edit that out
nick
i don't need this sort of harassment
from my wife
now why has it changed i feel like it's
changed over time a lot of men
you know don't want to have sex as much
and women want to have sex
more do you think it's like the media
that makes us think that
a lot of biological changes across a
lifespan right and so you gotta
you gotta pay attention to everybody's
biology and and if you don't work to
maintain it like
women after menopause things just die
and that needn't be you can do hormone
replacement i do i'm doing a lot of
podcasting about the pellets and things
like that that help women
really enjoy their life more i mean they
are miserable when they are menopausal
and they are so much better
mentally testosterone replacement you
meant to it's a little you know it's a
little lower level
replacement kind of thing and but in
extreme cases
i've i've known men um particularly head
trauma patients
i talked to a personal friend of mine
who was a marine and he served
uh overseas and he he had serious trauma
and his hormone levels because of that
yeah
we're i'm not talking low they were
non-existent yeah literally he had no
testosterone
depression oh yeah he started doing the
trt and it
literally saved his life yeah it's not
hyperbole people have to be yeah
people have to pay attention you should
because a lot of a lot of
what goes down is depression in the 50s
and 60s in women is actually just
menopausal syndrome or perimenopause in
their 30s and 40s
the point is you can keep things really
going so
and i've always said that you know
whatever that thing is that's there
at the beginning with your wife if you
can keep that every day if every day
that's still there
that's a successful marriage yeah dude
yeah but it's but you don't have to
you have to worry about 10 years down
the line if tomorrow is the same as
today
one step at a time but when you were
shoot when you were not choosing your
right but when you guys
chose each other were you able to notice
some of those things in advance because
i feel like you meet a girl and you're
like who knows what's in here
yeah yeah no it's a leap of faith let's
be fair but dude
i had a strange reaction to her where i
met her twice and i'm
really shy i can't go out people and i
didn't know it was the same person
and i i had to talk to her both times oh
wow
and gave her my number both time which
i've never done like ever wow
yeah and she was like yeah and i didn't
learn it was her this
the sec until we'd been dating a year
and i saw a picture of the night where i
met her the first time i was like oh you
were there that night oh my god that was
you
that's cool yeah she's like i'm dating
this guy with autism
[Music]
is